comprehensible compelling input is fine
but it's something where we need an
assist hi there steve goffin here today
and i'm going to talk to you today about
ci
which can be compelling input or
comprehensible input and i'm going to
talk about the limits of ci
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
uh if you're on a podcast service uh you
know please leave a review i appreciate
it
so
if you follow me on these on my youtube
channel you'll know that i'm a great
believer in stephen krashen's input
hypothesis that we learn languages
through input
and that ideally that input should be an
input means essentially listening and
reading
uh
that that input should be
comprehensible
and meaningful and ideally compelling
and so this then is the term ci and
there's a whole
range of teaching activities that have
developed around this concept of
creating ci
compelling or comprehensible
of course for input to be compelling it
has to be comprehensible it can be
comprehensible and boring
but it can't be
it's difficult for it to be compelling
and not comprehensible
although it can be of great interest but
you don't fully understand it so to that
extent it's semi-comprehensible but very
compelling but at any rate ci ingesting
comprehensible compelling input
meaningful messaging as crash and refers
to it the more of this
quantity of meaningful messages we get
the more our brain starts to become
familiar with the language and we
acquire words
and familiarity with the language and
eventually we end up being able to speak
the language
so i i do believe in in the power of ci
and i think these methods new methods of
language destruction built around ci are
good
but i also feel there are certain limits
first of all when we start in a new
language nothing is comprehensible
because you don't know the language
you're starting at zero obviously
if you're going from spanish to
portuguese
some things are comprehensible at least
when you read
even as an english speaker if we see
something in french or spanish there are
words there that we recognize
so some things are comprehensible but
generally speaking especially if we're
listening to it it's not comprehensible
so to start off you know right at the
beginning you know we can't start with
comprehensible input so we have to have
some
way of getting
you know stepping us ourselves up
empowering ourselves up to a point where
we are actually able to deal with
comprehensible input
as i've said that's where i use the mini
stories at link because the and i like
the idea of a lot of repetition i have a
high degree of tolerance for
repetition uh of relatively
uninteresting content because i'm very
motivated at first to at least get a
toehold in the language
after a while i get tired of this but
initially i'm quite capable of
subjecting myself to
repetitive content repetitive listening
repetitive reading
looking up words
in order to get a toehold of the
language
the second thing about comprehensible
input
and i've read now quite a bit on the
subject people like pollination in new
zealand and others
there's a lot of material available on
the internet if you search
comprehensible input extensive reading
you can find lots of information
and one of the sort of traditional
approaches to this idea of of using
input to acquire the language is to say
that
using the example of the native speaker
who apparently learns a thousand words a
year
and the native speaker learns a thousand
words a year because the native speaker
has so much exposure to his or her own
language whether it be listening or
reading
and so the native speaker doesn't need
to look words up the native speaker can
infer meaning can guess that meaning
gets these words in so many different
contexts that they simply become part of
the sort of active vocabulary words and
phrases expressions new expressions new
slang words they hear them on tv they
read them here or there and that becomes
part of their vocabulary
[Applause]
for someone learning a foreign language
it's more difficult
so
there was one paper i read which talked
about maximum two percent
unknown words so that's one in 50
unknown words that's kind of the level
you need to be at so that you can sort
of naturally learn these words
by guessing or by
encountering these words in different
contexts and gradually getting a sense
of what they mean
you know
to acquire words
that way
would be tremendously time consuming
because as i've said many times
frequency drops off very quickly so
for the first thousand words where there
are a lot of what they call function
words like
uh you know
the and uh buy with from iue
common verbs
that's all there in the first thousand
and we get those so often that we learn
them there
it is possible to acquire them through
acquire them through context in in
more or less comprehensible input it's
not ideal in my opinion if you're
dealing with a foreign language if i
were to start on finish in link i would
want to look up every word i want to
know which word is by or with or because
and i'll forget it but i'll look it up
again
and that way that speeds me along
otherwise i will just be looking at the
string of five words and i don't know
which one is the verb which one is a buy
with because from and i looked them up
and eventually
i remember what i looked up not at first
but i do eventually
and it's but never in any case the first
thousand words are easier the second
thousand words we're now dealing with
words that don't show up that often
where you would have to you know because
again theoretically you need to meet a
word eight times according to some
research in order to have a 50 chance of
remembering that word well
uh words that don't show up very often
that might show up five times in a whole
book
you've got to read a lot of books
in order to meet that word often enough
to remember it and particularly if
you're relying
on you know inferring or guessing the
meaning of that word if you're able to
look it up if as that link you have
differential you know
highlighting to remind you that you've
seen the word before if you have
you know lists that you can review after
you've finished a lesson all of these
different things can help you
you know acquire these words more
quickly so that you don't need to rely
on being able to read
through
material that is so easy for you that
there's only two percent unknown words
you actually can read material that's
more difficult
and that way
by using something like link or if even
if you're reading on your kindle and you
look up words in a dictionary or
whatever it might be
uh you're able to deal with more than
two percent unknown words and every time
you look the word up you tuck it away
somewhere you forget it but you're
working your way through
you're making that input comprehensible
you're not deliberately trying to hang
on to those words you're making the
input comprehensible and in time
those words as you meet them again and
again are going to become a part of your
vocabulary so
again comprehensible compelling input is
fine but it's something where we need an
assist another assist is audio if you
can hear it as well as listen to it you
get some momentum into your reading you
get
sort of
a combined effect which is again going
to help you retain the vocabulary and
ultimately the goal is to acquire enough
vocabulary and familiarity with the
language that you can read more and more
so it's a bit of a snowball situation
the more words you have the more new
words you can learn the more you're
enjoying the process because as you
acquire more words you can deal with
content that's of greater interest and
of course you can choose to focus your
activities so that
you know
what determines i mentioned this system
in the uk where they want to say you
must learn these 1700 words well
if my interest is in nuclear physics or
it's in nature or it's in economics then
i might actually acquire and learn and
remember some very low frequency
words that are relevant to my area of
interest and so we can actually control
to some extent what low frequency words
we're going to encounter and make sure
that we encounter them over and over
again and then every so often we can
change to another call it domain where
we again will be encountering words
somewhat more frequently we can have you
know a strategy along those lines
uh
at link we let you know what percentage
new words there are in any content you
want to import or any anything you may
find in our library and typically for me
15 unknown words is kind of a sweet spot
i know that that if i were to
spend time and effort to listen to and
read items with about 15 unknown words
i'm gonna be really improving increasing
you know creating more links as we said
link adding to my vocabulary improving
my ability to understand
more and more demanding material
so
uh
the idea that sort of comprehensible
input just go out and read and enjoy
yourself
i think it's a little more complex than
that uh i think if you rely solely on
being able to infer meaning
without looking words up in the
dictionary without making that a little
extra effort to learn the words
the amount of material that you would
have to consume would be hours and hours
and hours and on the other hand there
are so many words to learn that if you
were to rely solely on
say
flashcard activities like anki then you
would deny yourself
the pleasure of listening and reading
the whole familiarity with the language
that comes through that kind of activity
so you need a bit of a mixture in my
opinion something between
purely extensive reading or on the other
hand deliberate vocabulary study in
order to
make that input you know push you
forward and there's no question that if
you can achieve a high level of
comprehension both oral and written
your speaking ability will come along
and all of that
doesn't require you to be
you know totally accurate in your use of
grammar that will improve over time
and shouldn't testing you on grammar
which is often discouraging shouldn't be
sort of an obstacle to getting people
moving forward in the language so
comprehensible input as the core
but sensible comprehensible input
where
modern tools are used to help people
progress more quickly that's what i
think is most effective
and i'll leave you a couple of videos
that i've done on similar subject
subjects in the past and again remember
please subscribe
to my videos
and please send along your comments
thank you for listening